Hello there!
Ms. Coffee Bean,
the audience has spoken! The last video
was about positional embeddings with
sines and cosines, as it was introduced
in the “Attention is all you need paper”.
You wrote us in the comments that you want
to know even more about positional encodings,
so here it is! Again, a video about them!
This video is about the question:
When to add or when to concatenate positional
embeddings to the initial input representation?
Then we will talk a bit about
learned positional embeddings.
So welcome to this AI Coffee Break, your
coffee infusion enabling you to become
a positional embedding expert.
Or not.
First, lets’ dive a little bit into the two
ways to handle positional embeddings in general.
In the last video, we showed the
“attention is all you need”-way
where positional embeddings are added to the
vector initial representations of tokens.
Then we have seen what an act
of balance this addition is.
By the way, if you did not watch the video, now is
the time, go watch it and come back here for more.
No, Ms. Coffee Bean, not you! You
stay here and do this video with me.
So when adding the positional
encodings to the vector representation,
ideally they contain some semantic information
about the token already, but we would like
to make the positional information strong
enough so the model does not overlook it.
And also not too strong so it does not overtone
the semantic similarities in that vector space.
A proof that this is indeed an act of balance is
the division by 10,000 in the
arguments of the sines and cosines.
Finding the correct order of magnitude
of the frequency is not straightforward.
And all these problems come why? Because we
add positional embeddings to word vectors
and risk mixing up information.
So of course, people have been also
trying other things to counter this,
like concatenating positional
embeddings instead of adding them.
This opens a whole new dimension of possibilities,
quite literally.
Now the semantic information has
its own dimensions to live in
and positional information is encoded
somewhere else, in an orthogonal,
thus unrelated space to the semantic one.
This completely avoids an information mess,
but comes at a cost: memory, parameters,
runtime, all the bad things!!
We could let the positional embeddings
have their own dimensions in two ways:
If we have the parameter budget, we could
add extra dimensions for encoding position.
In terms of compute, it is
like going from BERT base
to BERT large.
This luxury comes at a cost, where these
extra dimensions will then negatively
impact the memory and computation
footprint down the line in the
attention computation and number of neurons
in the fully connected layers afterwards.
The other option is to take some of the
dimensions away from the word vectors
and use them only for positional information; this
means that the semantic representational capacity
of the model is reduced; it's like
going from BERT large to BERT base.
So to take a bird-eye view again: adding
positional embeddings to word vectors
is for the poor but balanced ones that
do not afford the extra model capacity,
but can keep their position on the thin line
between semantic or positional takeover.
Concatenation is for the rich, in the sense
that they have larger GPUs with more memory,
or perhaps are lucky with simpler
tasks that do not need a model with
greater expressivity to better capture
[mhm] memorize semantic information.
Maybe adding and concatenating are not
that different after all. At least,
this is perhaps why there is no clear winner
here when we think about performance on tasks of
added versus concatenated positional embeddings.
What if in these high dimensions that we
cannot imagine, the word vectors and positional
embeddings are almost orthogonal anyway?
So it would be actually safe to add them
because the model could disentangle
them in the next layers already.
Ms. Coffee Bean isn’t sure about this though.
But one thing is clear: concatenation ensures
orthogonality and no mix-up. Adding
the positional embeddings does not
and it still seems to work just fine
with a little bit of tuning
and has lower computational cost.
But ok, I get it. You do not want to
do the tuning yourself. So why shouldn't
you do what every machine learner does?
Let the transformer figure out for itself what
it needs as positional embeddings Let the child,
or the machine learn by itself!
And here we are already in the realm
of learned positional embeddings; a realm visited
by language models like BERT, RoBERTa, GPT-2,
and where image models like ViT
and DeiT have experimented too.
Especially when you have no idea about how to
hand-craft positional encodings for your data
because you’re working with modalities that
are not so explored in terms of positional
embeddings like text is… why not learn them?
Interestingly enough, this idea of learnable
positional embeddings precedes the “Attention
is all you need” paper and aims to learn some
vectors, which you can add to your input with
the same procedure as with any other parameter
in your model: with SGD and backpropagation.
And hereby, the network learns interesting and
sometimes surprising things! For example, masked
language modelling objectives in BERT or RoBERTa
seem to enforce less structure on the positional
embeddings than autoregressive models like GPT-2.
A model that must complete the sequence left to
right, has more incentives to focus on position.
And we can see this in this cosine similarity
plot of positional embeddings in GPT2;
positional embeddings become similar to
their neighboring position, similarity
which grows weaker while going further in the
sequence. But also long-term relations emerge
with embeddings having high cosine similarity to
embeddings farther away, in a periodic pattern.
In BERT, this looks very different with positional
embeddings that have only a very narrow pattern.
This kind of makes sense because
replacing a masked word is much
more dependent on the immediate neighbors.
But the thing with learned positional embeddings
is: They do not seem to consistently
outperform their handcrafted variants.
The “attention is all you need” paper,
tried out learned positional embeddings
long before BERT but it did not seem
to outperform their handcrafted,
Fourier inspired sinusoidal embeddings.
And you have no idea how much sense it
makes to Ms. Coffee Bean because
it is very similar to the evolution
of self-attention that has been recently
hand-crafted with the Fourier Transform!
It seems like research is going in a circle.
Or rather a spiral because there is progress.
But look, the original transformer paper tried out
handcrafted sinusoidal positional encodings and
learned ones, but could not measure
the superiority of one over the other.
Then BERT, RoBERTa, GPT-2 and so on all came
and advertised learned positional embeddings.
Learned positional embeddings have also been
tried out in “An image is worth 16x16 pixels”
with ViT but also with no significant gains
over the default encodings that were just
numbering image patches, so again
a loss for the learned version.
But let’s zoom out a bit because this is
exactly what happens with attention too!
Learned, quadratically scaling attention
has been haunting us for a while now,
but lately, there have been
alternatives, like the FNet,
completely hard-coding self-attention with
the Fourier Transform (where the idea is super
similar to sinusoid positional embeddings).
I don’t know, but Ms. Coffee Bean sees these
parallels between the opinion oscillation
in the community between learned or not so
learned self-attention replacements and between
hard-coded and learned positional embeddings.
So what are your favorites? Are you following
the church of added or the church of
concatenated positional embeddings?
Are you more a fan of learned or of hand-crafted
positional embeddings? Let us know in the
comments. And as requested by you, the next video
will be about relative positional embeddings.
It does not fit in this video because
your coffee break is now already over!
Go back to work. Or whatever you else need to
do like... watch another AI Coffee Break video.
Like and subscribe!
Okay bye!